see this flag it's a floored flag also
known as a coffin fly flies like these
provide crucial evidence in solving
mysterious deaths E6 Never Lie insects
are tiny Witnesses with my job as
forensic entomologist I use these tiny
witnesses to give Justice to victims
wired spoke with Dr Paula magni to
understand how insects can be used to
help solve suspicious deaths
thank you
the forensic entomologist is one of the
many experts that work at the crime
scene in order to provide more
information to the course of an
investigation the post-mortem interval
or PMI is considered the time since
death it is pretty much the time between
the moment of death to the
identification of a dead body they can
provide an alibi to somebody or destroy
an alibi for somebody else
turn Italy case one the victim was a
female that was found wrapped in a
blanket and covered by a carpet the
pathologist could not estimate a time
since that the body was highly
decomposed typically the Pathologists
work within the 72 hours after death
after this time nature takes over and
the typical signs of that the rigor
mortis algor mortis liver mortis cannot
be used anymore but this is exactly the
perfect time for the insects to colonize
the body and start what we call the
biological clock that is what forensic
entomologists use to investigate and
estimate the time since death estimating
the PMI in this case relied on analyzing
the life cycle of flies through
development from egg to adults can be
predicted based on environmental
conditions insects grow faster or slower
based on the environmental temperature
and and there were maggot masses active
on the body so if outside there were 25
degrees inside of the mega Mass nearly
28 degrees my job in that case was to
collect the maggots considering the
species and temperature to backtrack the
time since that that case was very
complex there was already somebody
suspected of this murder but the insects
were giving different information giving
an alibi to this suspect the time since
that was around the same time of a long
exchange of messages and phone call with
a certain person helped the
investigators investigate specifically
on someone else ask the right questions
and close the case
turn Italy cases two
some musics are interested in the fresh
decomposition some highly decayed and
some when body is just Bones based on
the kind of insect I can find I can
understand from how long the body is
there so my job was to participate into
the investigation if this person was
that since the last time he was seen
alive or if there was something going on
the body was nearly mummified by the
bugs and specifically one type of bugs
that are called the Larder beetles
created a very strange structure they
were looking like threads on the body
when the body is mummified or when I
find just Bones on a very old body I use
another technique that is called the
successional waves methodology
successional waves refers to the
different types of insects that are
found at different stages of
decomposition using this method allows
forensic entomologists to estimate PMI
for older cases the case of the
Forgotten men was pretty complex because
is there was an association of different
type of insects we had to identify which
insects were belonging to the body and
which one to the house all of these
insects were giving us information about
how many successional ways had passed by
to estimate the time since that we
realized that the body was laying in the
place where we found it for at least a
year and a half
Western Australia case three when we
watched CSI or similar TV programs most
of the time investigators found the
presence of a body on the ground reality
is that the majority of the cases bodies
are found contained in something we
consider that as limited access
environment insects have a physical
impediment to reach the body but they
don't give up insects really try their
best to reach the body because the body
means food and the body means place for
the offsprings to grow and survive and
blowflies will lay eggs on the zip and
the female of coffin flies can pass
through the zip and reach the body so
there is this consuming food chain that
happened inside of a suitcase that is
very interesting because what we find
inside is what ever happened before so
we can find different successions and we
can work on that to identify from how
long the body is in inside of a suitcase
despite these cases happen all around
the world and pretty often the research
is really scanned because it's very
difficult to perform such a huge
research my group of research is
developing this to find out how insects
can interact with the body during the
winter period in suitcases compared to
Trash Can This research will allow us to
give more information to investigators
if cases like this happen in Western
Australia forensic entomology is really
holistic from the point of view as a
discipline because you consider insects
also had to consider the investigative
process and has to combine the
information from the insects with the
information about the environment the
meteorology and at the specific crime
scene what I'm trying to do with my work
is to use this little piece of nature to
give Justice to the victim